>> Laura: PRESIDENT TRUMP
FIRED BACK AT CRITICS WHO
CLAIMED MEETING WITH THE
NORTH KOREAN LEADER WOULD BE A
MAJOR CONCESSION.
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED:
"WOW, WE HAVEN'T GIVEN UP
ANYTHING."
LET'S DISCUSS THE MEETING WITH
IAN BREMMER.
HIS NEW BOOK "US VERSUS THEM,"
THE FAILURE OF GLOBALISM.
COMES OUT TOMORROW.
YOU CAN TELL I AM STILL IN MY
MIND IN LAW SCHOOL.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU.
THIS IS, I THINK WITH ALL THE
INVESTIGATION MEDIA GOING ON AND
ALL
THE DAILY FOOD FIGHT IN
WASHINGTON.
THIS COULD BE, COULD BE, AN
UNBELIEVABLE DEVELOPMENT.
THERE IS A LOT OF APPS.
EVEN A MODICUM OF PRAISE OR
RESPECT FOR THE FACT THAT WE ARE
LEASED TAKING A DIFFERENT
APPROACH TO NORTH KOREA WITH ALL
OF THE PREDICTIONS OF GLOBAL
UNREST AND HE'S GOING TO START
WORLD WAR III, THIS IS
SOMETHING.
IT'S QUITE SOMETHING.
>> TRUMP FULLY DESERVES CREDIT.
THE FACT THAT HE WAS WILLING TO
PUSH HARD THAT BROUGHT THE
CHINESE TO THE TABLE SUPPORTING
U.S. DRIVEN SECURITY COUNCIL
RESOLUTIONS AND SQUEEZING THEM
ON SANCTIONS, IT CONCERNED THE
NORTH KOREANS, GOT THEM TO SHOW
UP AT THE OLYMPICS.
GOT THEM TO BE WILLING TO ENGAGE
WITH THE SOUTH KOREANS.
THE CHINESE.
ALSO AGREED TO SUSPEND MISSILE
TESTING AND NUCLEAR TESTING
WITHOUT OFFERING ANYTHING FROM
THE UNITED STATES.
WE HAVE OFFERED THEM A SUMMIT.
THEY WANTED.
PROVIDES LEGITIMACY.
IF YOU ASK WHO HAS DONE MORE
BENDING SO FAR, NORTH KOREA OR
UNITED STATES, CLEARLY THE
NORTH KOREANS.
IT'S FAR FROM SAYING WE ARE
GOING TO GET TO DENUCLEARIZATION
ON THE PART OF PYONGYANG BUT
ABSOLUTELY THERE'S MORE OF A
CHANCE WE SEE A BREAKTHROUGH
TODAY THAN THERE WAS SIX MONTHS
AGO.
>> Laura: YOU MADE AN
INTERESTING TWEET, SENT AN
INTERESTING TWEET ABOUT THE
NOBEL PEACE PRIZE.
TELL US.
>> ONLY THE FACT THAT IF IT WERE